Marc Scott Zicree, Screenwriter/Author: I
am here to provide a service and if I can
open a door for someone where they understand
that it's not as hard as people make it sound,
you know that's the trick of it…
Film Courage: Marc, what do you think makes
you different than the thousands of other
screenwriters who came to Los Angeles during
your time here?
What do you think made it different for you?
Marc: Well I think I was very, very lucky
in the fact that I was enthusiastic about
science fiction from when I was a small boy
and science fiction (unlike a lot of other
genres) the fans became the writers and so
they had a sense of wanting to pay it forward.
When I noticed that the same writers were
writing for Star Trek and Outer Limits and
Twilight Zone as we're writing the short stories
and books that I was reading and the novels
Ray Bradbury, Harlan Ellis and Theodore Sturgeon,
Richard Matheson, etc.
I could then go to science fiction conventions
when I was a teenager and I sought these wonderful
people out and they became mentors and friends
that that helped enormously and and also I
just had such a passion for writing I had
such a I had a sense of calling from a very
early age and I understood that because of
rod sterling because of so many of these writers
that I admired that you could aim high you
didn't have to blend in you just had to be
clear what you were sharing with the world
and Ray Bradbury was a mentor of mine for
over 10 years i'd go over to his house once
a month for over 10 years toward the end of
his life and ray always used to say look inward
don't look out for your mature look inward
and that doesn't mean that you can't write
about things that are different from your
life it just means that you find your passions
and the your true self inward and then you
put that out to the world and and so I had
extremely good teachers in that way because
I think some writers out of fear feel that
they have to imitate others or write down
to their audience I've never felt that I'm
the same as my audience and if I come across
an idea or a story or characters or whatever
that excites me usually my audience will be
excited too by what I'm doing and I trust
my audience I don't I they're they're I feel
I'm with my family when when I'm talking to
all the weirdos weirdos are good things yeah
I like weirdos yeah yeah yeah how did you
know that you could actually get something
made I mean there's a lot of people who love
a certain genre but they dabble in it or they're
on the sort of the outside the outer limits
so to speak how did you know though that you
could get something made and eventually be
successful at it well I didn't I didn't have
a in terms of knowing that I would be successful
I didn't know that it was there are basically
two people who are responsible for my career
more than anyone which is my wife Elaine who
I met when I was 20. we got married when I
was 21 now we've been together 45 years and
married 44 and we write and produce and direct
together and my friend Michael Reeves who
was writing for television and brought me
into animation when I was like 22 23 years
old so I started by knowing by the time I
got out of art school about my degrees in
painting sculpture and graphic arts from ucla
and because I always knew I was going to be
an artist or a writer but by the time I went
through college and then went to the clarion
writers workshop and sold my first short story
I knew I was going to be a writer and so I
thought well how do you learn how to be a
writer in television and there was really
no there was no graduate school in that at
the time we're talking the late 70s and so
I thought well i'll write a book about one
of the greatest television shows ever made
to learn how to make great television and
so that's why what gave me the idea to to
do the Twilight Zone Companion it was two
years after Rod Serling's death and had Rod
not died prematurely terribly sadly at age
50.
I wouldn't have embarked upon that book because
if anyone should have written a book about
the Twilight Zone it would have been Rod but
since he wasn't with us anymore I thought
well let me follow this and see where it leads
now Elaine was invaluable because I started
writing the book interviewing over 100 people
who had worked on the show and it started
getting rejected when I started submitting
it it was rejected by 25 publishers over a
two-year period and probably if I would if
i'd been left to my own devices I would have
probably quit and Elaine said no no just keep
going and but we also looked at what wasn't
working which was the agent I had wasn't the
right agent she wasn't she wasn't seeing opportunity
to close the deal and so we I switched agents
to someone who was young and hungry and she
sold it almost immediately to one of the publishers
who already rejected it but a different editor
who had grown up with the twilight zone and
understood why people would want to read about
that and and the other thing I think that
was responsible for my success was sometimes
people are so dogged about this is all i'll
do like I mean you know Elaine and I have
mentored a lot of people and one person they
said well I'm I want to act in a Steven Spielberg
movie and we said well you know there's a
lot of other things being cast you could you
could try for other things no no Stephen's
it's got to be Steven Spielberg and so and
we said you know well he might only do one
movie every few years and and it might not
have a role that's right for you you're limiting
your possibilities so I knew I wanted to be
in television and I knew that I wanted to
be writing for shows like star trek but when
my friend Michael Reeves was writing animation
and he said would you like to come in and
collaborate with me I saw that as that got
me into television and then I could write
spec live action features and so forth and
that moved me then into live-action tv shows
but that's how I ended up writing for Smurfs
and He-Man and super friends and and all those
shows and but I always brought my a-game to
everything I did so I wasn't writing down
at all someone once asked me when I was writing
for animation they said do you write for the
child in the audience and I said no I write
for the child and myself and so I would go
to that place that would be delighted by the
jokes or by the stories and then just write
as truthfully as I possibly could and and
that worked and so I've I'm very proud of
the work I did in animation as well as the
work I've done in live action I am here to
provide a service and if I can open a door
for someone where they understand that it's
not as hard as people make it sound you know
that's the trick of it you know it's like
that's why I wrote green lighting yourself
so people would know that they could be the
engine that drives their career they don't
have to give up power they don't have to wait
for the studios and the networks or the publishing
companies even to see their value because
thanks to the internet thanks the fact we
all have cameras in our pockets thanks the
fact we can edit on on a mac or a pc there's
no reason not to just make the thing you want
to make give it all of your heart and soul
and put it out to the world that's your audience
and that's how you build a body of work you
don't have to wait there's no reason to can
you succeed in Hollywood if you're not a workaholic
yes you can succeed in Hollywood if you're
not a workaholic but you do have to have a
work ethic and it's interesting in green lighting
yourself in the new book I talk about having
a life and I deliberately put it after the
chapter on building from success and recovering
from failure and I pointed I pointed out in
the book that whether you're succeeding or
whether you're failing it's important to have
a life separate from that because the separate
having people who love you family friends
travel doing things separate from the work
it gives you a breadth of experience but it
also gives you a life it gives you something
that grounds you because you're not just someone
running after the brass ring and so actually
I know writers who have a very balanced life
between family and the work and I think that's
a good idea I don't think one should work
all the time because you run out of things
to draw upon creatively but you also run out
of I mean you just go crazy the isolation
Hollywood can drive people crazy simply because
they get so materialistic they get so success-oriented
driven that they forget why they got involved
in the first place you know I've known people
who've wanted to become who want to become
writers because they want to get rich and
I've never seen it work maybe someone has
succeeded that but the people that I've seen
succeed are the ones who just love the work
and they love what they're creating and they
are just so grateful for the opportunity and
you know it's just there's something like
for instance I just came from a studio that
I have that's filled with spaceship sets and
and you know we we're building an alien spaceship
we're building this hospital in a state a
space station and to be just and we're building
eight-foot-tall creatures and just to be in
that world and be able to share that world
with with everyone is is great but Elaine
[Zicree] and I try and stop working in the
early evening we work at least five days a
week and sometimes we'll work weekends but
we try not to but we we'll work and then the
evening for an hour or two we'll just relax
and watch a movie or a tv show or something
or go for a walk or you know we and we have
own dogs and dogs force you to like get off
the sofa stop typing you know go take them
for a walk and and that helps let the air
in a bit you can't I don't think you can be
successful if you don't have a work ethic
and also I think you have to stand by your
word the more you stand by your your word
the more you have a work ethic the more you
have at least craft if not I don't use the
word talent much because I've seen a lot of
people who had talent who got nowhere whereas
if you have passion and craft and a work ethic
and and you I mean you know the reason people
support me in so many ways is because if I
say I'm going to do something I do it and
it doesn't matter if it's easier if it's hard
if it's hard then it's hard it's I'm not going
to stop I'm not going to turn back I have
I have work to do you know I get on with it
and my mantra to myself when things are difficult
is you know I'm made of iron and nothing will
stop me and there are times for instance when
I did the star trek episode with George Takei
it was a very grueling shoot and and I said
I'm made of iron and nothing will stop me
and I had to use that but we got to the finish
line and that got nominated for the Hugo and
the Nebula and I’m very very proud of that
episode still and that was for Christina Moses's
first tv role we cast her out of the blue
and she's now starring on a million little
things on abc so we saw what her amazing talent
was right from the beginning well you talked
about talent and talent is very long in this
in this town but but what if someone's sort
of the pendulum swings more toward a hedonistic
personality type well I try not to hang out
with meanies they're gonna be a really nice
hedonist yeah they know but I mean I think
you have to treat your body like a car that
you might own and you want to take care of
it you want to make sure that you aren't burning
the candle at both ends you know so many people
burn out and you know drugs alcohol you know
self-destructive behaviors gambling all that
I it's just not sustainable in the long run
because it's just too hard on on your mind
and your body you know it's you know I gravitate
toward people who have a family life most
of the people I work with are married they
have many of them have kids I want someone
who's stable I don't want someone where I
don't know if they're going to show up and
so I can make the choice of who I work with
and I've been very lucky in terms of the actors
I've worked with even when I was at the studios
and the networks I never had a crazy person
I always had people who were there to do the
job and they appreciated the fact that I was
really putting putting everything I could
on the page and they would get these scripts
they would love what I was writing because
it gave them something to act some emotional
through line and and you know so quality work
gets you quality actors get you quality composers
and get there's a ripple effect if you're
if you're doing your your best work but you
can't be thinking about oh I've got this party
to go to I've got this no it's I mean that
doesn't mean you can't have fun you can't
go on vacation you can't go water skiing or
whatever you know and but but at the end of
the day you have to be reliable and that means
you have to like look ahead you cannot be
such an impulse monster that you know it's
Monday and you don't know where you're supposed
to be you know so can't wander the streets
but you know so so that's yeah but of course
in you know in the new book I talk about if
you if you have thrown together with someone
like that here's how you can deal with it
because I had a friend who was an actress
and she was cast on tv show huge hit show
and the the the star of the show was drinking
all day and being very very abusive to people
and very insulting and she just but she recognized
to not engage to do her work she was there
to do her work and she did it and ironically
at the end of the day the actor came up and
said you were great and so she had succeeded
I think often what we have to do is have our
eye on the ball in terms of what we are there
to accomplish it's not about winning every
single battle it's not about going toe-to-toe
with everyone it's not an alpha dog contest
it's about what am I trying to accomplish
and so if you say okay well I'm here to write
a great script and turn it into a great tv
show or I'm here to give a great performance
whatever it is you have to be clear on it
but obviously the more that you take power
the less you're going to be frustrated by
other people who are not there for the same
purpose so that's why I have my own studio
now that's why I raise money the way I do
because you know it's fun to be in charge
because then then there's no one around to
I mean if anyone's gonna wreck it it'll be
me but then that's my fault you know it's
like a failing of whatever but but it's so
it's so cool to work with great people and
create work that that has meaning you know
I just couldn't be happier.
Question For The Viewers:
Can you succeed in Hollywood if you’re not
a workaholic?